how do you define inclusive capitalism
how do you think it can be
um it can address the most pressing
issues
um especially equality of opportunity
specifically regarding gender race and
ethnicity age
and socio-economic background so
capitalism
in its best form is about
the the beauty of competition
to create the greatest product to create
the greatest
outcome but inherent in that
is an assumption that everyone starts
out on the same base
and then they compete and whoever wins
wins the market
right the market share but that's
a false assumption when you take into
account the fact that
not everyone comes starts from the same
place in particular when we take into
account
race and gender so
what we have to do is recognize the
disparities that have long exist
and existed and and take that into
consideration
when we want to encourage competition
and that includes for example what i'm
doing around
women own small businesses minority
owned small businesses
and giving people equal access to
compete
that at its core will produce the best
outcome for all for the customer for
society
for our economy and in the interest of
of of the best of what capitalism
should encourage and create